the human brain may not look like much a
couple of pounds of pink wrinkled tissue
but the last hundred years of
neuroscience have shown that the brain
is an incredibly densely wired computer
made out of hundreds of billions of
individual cells called neurons neurons
communicate with each other using both
chemical and electrical signals when a
neuron is activated by chemical
messengers it produces an electrical
pulse that results in similar chemical
signals being sent to other neurons to
which it is connected neurons come in
thousands perhaps tens of thousands of
different kinds each with a unique shape
a distinct molecular composition and a
unique pattern of connections within the
brain for example these cells the basket
cells have small input branches and
output branches and they release pulses
of chemical that inhibit their targets
whereas these cells the pyramidal cells
are large and project long distances and
they excite the cells they target if we
could figure out the role that each of
these cell types plays in the brain we
could understand how they work together
to create thoughts emotions and
behaviors and how flaws and specific
cell types may lead to devastating brain
disorders like schizophrenia Parkinson's
and depression now MIT researchers are
working to develop tools that allow us
to do exactly that it is now possible to
precisely control the activity of
specific neurons and therefore
understand how each neuron contributes
to brain function remarkably these
high-tech tools have come from
microorganisms such as this pond algae
called Chlamydomonas Chlamydomonas needs
light for photosynthesis and it swims
toward light with the help of a small
organelle called an eye spot the eye
spot contains a light-sensitive protein
called channelrhodopsin which responds
to blue light by moving positively
charged ions across the eye spot
membrane causing the voltage of the eye
spot to change a bit like a battery
being charged by a solar cell
but neurons are also electrical devices
and their voltage would also change if
channelrhodopsin could be inserted into
their membranes and then illuminated so
researchers took a piece of DNA that
encodes for the channelrhodopsin protein
then they put it into neurons using a
safe and effective method for delivering
a gene the same kind being used in human
gene therapy trials the neurons
expressed the DNA manufacturing copies
of the channelrhodopsin protein and
installing them in their membranes as
predicted the researchers were now able
to activate these neurons using lights
without affecting neighboring neurons
this technique called optogenetics
allows researchers to drive the activity
of specific neuron types to see how they
affect brain activity and behavior for
example researchers can deliver the
piece of DNA that encodes for
channelrhodopsin into a set of basket
cells shown here in green then pulses of
blue light activate only the basket
cells while the other cells for example
the neighboring pyramidal cells are not
affected so if a specific brain disorder
is associated with dysfunctional basket
cells it would be possible to augment
the activity of these cells and possibly
repair brain function and these tools
don't just activate neurons they can
silence them as well
our Kyra Dobson and halorhodopsin for
example are proteins that are sensitive
to orange light and produce the opposite
effect to channelrhodopsin when
researchers deliver DNA that encodes for
one of these molecules into a specific
set of cells and shine orange light
within the brain they can turn off just
the selected set of cells by combining
these tools along with others now being
developed researchers will be able to
control brain activity with a degree of
precision that would have been
unimaginable a few years ago opto
genetics is currently being used in
animal models to understand how normal
circuits work but it may also lead to
completely new types of prosthetics for
treating a wide
of human brain disorders